y acá la polémica que ahora pues está en
la mesa en los juegos olímpicos de
invierno beijing 2022 y para ello ya
está conmigo en el estudio juan pupiales
juan vamos entonces a seguir hablando de
la estrella del patinaje ruso camila
vale va que finalmente entonces ya se
confirmó que dio positivo por dopaje
juan si de raúl estamos ante una de las
deportistas olímpicas más jóvenes en
haber dado positivo por dopaje siendo de
la edad precisamente un factor que
apunta a ser clave en este caso este
viernes se confirmó ese positivo
caminaba lieva esa confirmación la de
suela agencia internacional de control
que es el organismo antidopaje que hay
menos juegos olímpicos de invierno
la muestra que arrojó este positivo se
realizó el 25 de diciembre en san
petersburgo durante los campeonatos
nacionales de patinaje de rusia sin
embargo el resultado no se conoció hasta
este martes algo que no ha gustado a las
autoridades olímpicas en rusas tanto
tiempo de espera entre la prueba y el
resultado ese día el martes el comité
olímpico ruso aplicó la suspensión
obligatoria que implican todos los
positivos 24 horas más tarde este mismo
comité levanto o la sanción a petición
de camila quien apeló esa suspensión
original y entonces le permitieron a
ella seguir entrenándose sin dar a
conocer los motivos para esa decisión
recordemos que ya participó el lunes en
la prueba por equipos en donde los rusos
ganaron el oro y ahora esta joven
patinadora tiene previsto participar en
la prueba individual que empieza ya el
martes la agencia internacional de
control se opone a que camila siga
compitiendo tal y como lo pretende
obviamente el comité olímpico ruso que
pasa ahora este caso queda en manos de
un panel del tribunal de arbitraje
deportivo que se encuentra en beijing y
quien es que tendrá hay quienes son
ellos quienes tendrán que decidir sobre
si esta patinadora continúa estando en
los juegos olímpicos de beijing 2022
hablamos de otro protagonista importante
la decisión le pregunto que dicen
entonces desde el comité olímpico
internacional juan grabado desde el
comité olímpico internacional no ellos
no ha celebrado esa entrega de medallas
del oro que ya ganó camila en la prueba
por equipos por un asunto legal es decir
ya estaban al tanto de que algo no
estaba bien con camila hoy esto fue lo
que dijo su portavoz
estos casos no son beneficiosos para los
juegos creo que con suerte la mayoría de
la gente ve que las 3000 personas
compitiendo aquí son deportistas
maravillosos son grandes deportistas y
esperamos que podamos seguir
concentrados en eso pero también se
puede apreciar que necesitamos perseguir
estos casos de manera adecuada cuidando
el debido proceso esto necesita
abordarse y donde no podemos pasar por
alto que rusia convirtió no juegos de
tokio y compiten ahora mismo en esos
juegos de beijing sin bandera porque
están cumpliendo una sanción por haber
mantenido un esquema de dopaje de estado
que tuvo su culmen en esos juegos
olímpicos de invierno de 2014 en sochi
en rusia estamos hablando del tema que
no es ajeno al gobierno de moscú tanto
así que este viernes el propio kremlin
se apresuró a pronunciarse sobre el caso
de camila esto por lo que dijeron mantén
tu cabeza en alto eres una rusa ve con
orgullo y ganarles a todos palabras de
dmitri peskov portavoz del kremlin que
quiso decir que eres una rusa pues creo
que nunca lo vamos a saber pero ahora
vamos a hablar de la sustancia que se
encontró en la muestra de camila
y me estás y dina que es mi puesto un
poco pronunciar pero yo creo que lo
logré
siempre tienen esos nombres complicados
eso es un agente metabólico que tiene la
capacidad de incrementar la eficiencia
sanguínea y por tanto mejorar la
resistencia con esa sustancia hay un
antecedente muy recordado en el
olimpismo es el caso de nadador chino
shun jump tres veces campeón olímpico y
quizás el nadador más famoso del gigante
asiático en 2014 ya no fue sancionado
con tres meses sin competir por esta
sustancia eso terminó con una gran
factura en contra de este nadador porque
años después el deportista chino se
opuso a un control antidopaje y con el
antecedente de su primera falta recibió
un castigo que le impidió participar en
los juegos olímpicos de tokio del verano
pasado en el caso de camila dado que
tiene solamente 15 años las reglas de la
agencia mundial antidopaje podrían
permitir que la sanción sea solamente un
llamado de atención y que se investigue
a sus entrenadores de hecho ahí puestos
en el mundo del patinaje que piden que
no se condena a camila porque ella es
prácticamente una niña la otra gran
incógnita además de la sanción de
camiones que va a pasar con la medalla
de oro que ya tiene el comité olímpico
de rusia eeuu fue plata en esa prueba y
bronce fue japón con esto se augura que
no habrá una decisión inmediata porque
primero la federación internacional de
patinaje tiene que esperar a que se
concluye todo este caso del dopaje de
camila para así tomar una decisión sobre
qué pasa con esa medalla de oro sobre la
que ya el comité olímpico rosa expresado
es que no le gustaría perderla